[Music]
22 years ago keanu reeves impressed fans
across the globe in his role as neo and
the matrix movie series after the last
part which was released 18 years ago the
prospect of another sequel was not
really promising as has now been known
for almost two years though in one of
the two original masterminds of the
trilogy lana vokowski is devoting her
attention to a fourth part expectations
couldn't be any higher which is why in
today's original we will be compiling
all the facts about the matrix 4 thus
far as well as doing a bit of
speculating regarding the plot
first let's talk about the cast as
already mentioned veteran store keanu
reeves can once again show what he's got
as neo
also bank will be colleague carrie and
moses trinity and that despite the fact
that they both originally lost their
lives at the end of the matrix
revolutions
most likely jada pinkett smith will also
rejoin the cast as niobe having played
one of zion's strongest fighters in the
last two parts
daniel bernard is also expected to be
seen again as agent johnson of course
many are wondering about the whereabouts
of the merovinian who like his wife
posiphony played a major role in the
film series lambert wilson and monica
bellucci could slip back into their
roles but this is not yet confirmed all
the more certain is an appearance by
aquaman starria abdulmadin ii who
according to the rumors is supposed to
embody a younger morpheus he himself was
neither able nor allowed to comment on
this in an interview with entertainment
weekly even though he would have loved
to talk about the matrix 4 as he said
himself if the rumors are true it
remains to be seen as to what will
happen to the original morpheus who was
played by lawrence fishburne the 60 year
old affirms that he was not cast for the
matrix 4 which in turn increases the
likelihood that abdel medin will indeed
play a young morpheus hugo weaving will
also have to say goodbye to his role as
agent smith as he was not asked to take
part in the project either instead there
are two prominent newcomers neil patrick
harris as well as iron fist star jessica
henwick both are said to play important
roles in the upcoming film also joining
the caster jonathan roth priyanka chopra
jonas andrew caldwell alan hallman and
stephen graham
now let's move on to the plot in fact
there is absolutely no information
whatsoever about what exactly the film
will be about the crux of the matter is
of course the fact that neo is alive
contrary to the events of the third
movie in the following we would like to
discuss some theories on how it comes to
be that neo is still alive or rather
alive again
the protagonist had to face his opponent
agent smith in the matrix revolutions
resulting in the machines killing both
neo and smith due to a power search
by making this sacrifice neo has
basically saved humanity and given it a
more peaceful future thanks to his
selfless act
many fans support the theory that neo
was not really deleted those of you who
are computer literate will know that it
is extremely difficult to really delete
something entirely from the digital
world only a specialist could certainly
retrieve a supposedly irrevocably
removed file by means of individual
fragments especially in the vast matrix
network it is quite plausible that a
version of the protagonist is actually
saved somewhere in the data and could be
brought back to life
if necessary this won't bring back his
physical body but within the matrix neo
could still exist
next the following aspect should not be
disregarded the possibility of time
travel we've known not just since the
mcu that many movies like to build on
the existence of different timelines
particularly in the extremely complex
world of the matrix time travel doesn't
sound like an all too bold idea this
theory is backed by the signing of the
presumably younger morpheus yaya abdul
madin ii of course the machines could
take neo and trinity from the past for
example and have them fight in the
future however then one would have to
explain somehow why the two look
significantly older than prior to the
death in the third part sure they could
also use various tricks to rejuvenate
the actors but we consider that rather
unlikely
another really interesting theory is
that kian reeves is not going to play
neo at all but instead the next version
of the chosen one after all after the
reset of the old simulation we don't
know exactly what the new one is
supposed to look like hence reeves could
easily play neo's successor a completely
new character in a completely new role
so to speak the chosen one could then
take longer to understand what's
happening around him this time it's kind
of a bizarre idea but one that isn't all
that far-fetched finally we'll introduce
you to the theory of neo's immortality
and the first the matrix part neo
impressively shows how he can heal
himself from a bullet wound sure you
could argue that this is no longer
possible once this source's power in
neo's body is extinguished in fact the
most popular theory about the matrix
film series is that it is an analogy to
the life of jesus he dies resurrects and
eventually sacrifices himself for the
people just like neo if you keep
thinking about this theory neo actually
didn't die at all he is just waiting for
the moment of his return fascinating
idea isn't it those were our four
theories on the plot and neos
whereabouts do you have any other ideas
on how things could continue feel free
to write your thoughts down in the
comments
to conclude let's take a look at the
production
as previously hinted at the matrix four
was written and directed by alana
vakowski along with the successful
authors alexander hammond and david
mitchell as reeves himself pointed out
the script resembles a love story and is
intended to be a sort of wake up call
for the audience shooting of the matrix
4 began in february 2020 and took mostly
place in san francisco as well as at
studio bubblesburg in potsdam germany
although it was temporarily hauled after
a few weeks due to the pandemic filming
finally ended in november of last year
the release date of the upcoming
blockbuster is actually scheduled for
this year on december 22nd 2021
there you go again with our latest
original if you like this video please
subscribe to our channel and hit the
notification bell so that you will
always be up to date in the future
see you next time
[Music]
you